all right so we're presenting on what
drugs could treat Koba 19 so hi everyone
um as our wonderful host mentioned I'm
Lindsay I'm a grad student at
Rockefeller University and I'm
originally from Connecticut which is
that star that's a little bit to the
left in red yeah and I'm Emily Costa I'm
studying at Weill Cornell and I'm
originally from Massachusetts so that
slightly shifted star it works all right
so um I'm actually when obviously
there's not a pandemic happening I'm
super interested in understanding how
behavior works and specifically how the
brain is able to generate sometimes
supercool and sometimes not so cool
behaviors and so I do this by studying
ants in Daniel cronauer's lab at
Rockefeller and as many of you might
know ants are actually a really great
system to study social behavior because
they live in colonies and they
communicate each other with each other
and they have division of labor so some
ants are specialized nursers and take
care of the young and some specialized
in foraging and look for food and they
all kind of work together to keep the
colony alive and happy and my research
specifically is focused on understanding
how ants which have I mean most of you
have probably seen an ant before they
have very small heads and very small
brains to go inside those heads but
they're still capable of these pretty
extraordinary social behaviors and so
actually on the left here I have a
picture of an ant brain and what my
research is focused on is figuring out
what brain pathways are important for
social behavior and specifically
communication between different ants to
coordinate their behavior um but I'm not
in the lab all the time and when I'm not
in the lab I really enjoy spending time
with my family you can see them on the
bottom left here I think some of them
might be watching but I grew up in
Connecticut and so it's really nice I
can just hop on the train and go home
and visit them and I also really really
love
animals you can see our family's dog was
in our family portrait I have two cats
we might see them like running around on
the cat tree I ask them to stay as calm
as possible but they don't really speak
human so we'll see
rustle of baking I think it's a really
nice way of sort of being creative and
experimenting it's especially nice at
times like now where I can't be in the
lab and finally I really love talking
about science and thinking about new
ways to communicate science so I love
volunteering with rocky to you I also
have done other outreach sorts of things
and specifically one that was really fun
was working with artists with
intellectual and developmental
disabilities to create bio art hi so I'm
Emily or M for short um and I'm
currently doing my PhD or graduate
school I'm currently in graduate school
at Weill Cornell but I actually do my
thesis research just down the street
over at sloan-kettering and Charlie
Rudin's lab and there I study a type of
lung cancer called small cell lung
cancer and in particular I'm trying to
understand how to make immunotherapy
work better for patients with small cell
lung cancer so immunotherapy is
basically a type of cancer therapy that
engages our body's immune defenses to
attack cancer cells so the kind of
immunotherapy that I in particular study
is called immune checkpoint blockade and
the way it works is basically there's
this interaction that happens between
tumor cells and immune cells
I'm involving two proteins PDL one which
is on the tumor cell and PD one which is
on the immune cell and normally these
two proteins interact actually is a
function of preventing autoimmunity
which is when our immune cells
accidentally attack our body's normal
healthy cells but tumor cells actually
use this mechanism as a way to hide
themselves from the immune system which
would otherwise are actually notice that
they're really admirable compared to our
healthy cells because they have so many
mutations so basically we figured out as
a therapy that if you block this
interaction using antibodies which can
either bind to PDL 1 or PD 1 and keep
them from binding to each other then you
can actually have the immune cells
specifically t-cells
notice the cancer cells so they can no
longer hide from the immune system and
then they can attack and kill those
cancer cells and start healing patients
tumors so it's a pretty cool technique
and as I mentioned my work is focused on
using this kind of therapy and making it
more effective in patients with small
cell lung cancer so when I'm not in the
lab doing science you can find me
talking about science pretty much
anywhere else so I really have a
volunteering with rocky to you both in
their lab Experience Program and also at
Science Saturday which is a program they
do every summer this is from the last
science Saturday where myself and a
couple of friends in grad school ground
up a lot of strawberries and then showed
some kids how to extract DNA from them
which is a really fun messy time um I
also talked about trivia and shared
science stories on a podcast called fax
machine that I run with some of my
friends from grad school it's funny and
punny and we have a lot of fun doing it
um I also really enjoy projects I kind
of look at the intersection of art and
science so for example last year I had
the really cool opportunity to work on a
project scripting a series of short
films about the history of women in
science and I also enjoy doing this kind
of photography called cyano typing that
folks in the 19th century actually used
to use to kind of catalog botanical
specimens and sort of like capture
images of plants now I do it because
it's just kind of a really pretty thing
to do and a nice hobby but that history
is kind of cool I think all right so the
paper that we're going to talk about
today is an example of scientific
literature but what do we mean by
scientific literature so literature as
we call it in the research world is how
scientists basically write about their
research and then communicate it to each
other in a way that's informative
expedience and trustworthy so as you can
imagine the first step in generating
scientific literature is actually doing
the research so scientists will be in
the labs running experiments collecting
data and then once they decide they have
research they'd like to share
then they'll write about it in a paper
and then this paper will go to two
places it can go to an open source
publisher a really popular one life
sciences is called bio archive and
papers that go open source are available
for anyone to read immediately which is
really helpful when the information that
the authors are sharing can be used by
other researchers really quickly like
koba 19 research it's especially useful
to have open source journals but a
caveat to this is that the papers that
go to open source publishers are not
peer-reviewed conversely
another place that papers can go is to
peer-reviewed journals so you've
probably heard of some of these like
nature science cell plus penis there are
loads and loads of them but here the
papers actually do get peer-reviewed and
then once they're published by the paper
then they can be read by people in the
scientific and medical community who
will then apply these findings towards
their own research so I want to take a
little bit more time though to kind of
explore the differences between open
source publishing and peer-reviewed
journals so to kind of talk about peer
review and explain what that actually
means
basically when authors submit a paper to
a journal the editor at that journal
will then forward that paper to other
experts in the field of the paper comes
from and those experts will who are also
scientists will look at the methods and
the data in the paper and basically
evaluate whether the experiments were
rigorous or whether more experiments
need to happen in order for the authors
to actually make the claim that they
make in the paper so this process can
involve the author's going back doing
more experiments you know resubmitting
to the journal maybe getting rejected by
the journal and submitting to another
one and starting peer review at that
journal
so although peer reviewed papers are
regarded with more confidence than open
source because they have this kind of
vetting process that's built in it also
takes a lot more time for papers that
undergo peer review to actually be put
out what people can read them another
main difference between open source
publishers and peer-reviewed journals is
the degree of access that people have to
these papers so some journals actually
require that scientists pay them to
publish their papers which can then
limit where and
their labs can publish and additionally
some journals also require that you pay
a fee or house or have a subscription to
read the papers in them which can then
as you imagine also limit who gets to
read those papers a lot of journals
nowadays are moving more towards an open
access model where you can actually meet
their stuff for free but overall that
whole situation is avoided and with open
source publishers and one more kind of
limitation to access that Clegg's
scientific literature in general no
matter where it goes is jargon so
scientists write usually using a lot of
jargon which are basically technical
terms that are kind of difficult to
digest if you're not a specialist or not
in the fields that the terms come from
which can make the literature you know
difficult to access for people who are
not in the field but it's also why we do
data for the people so there are ways to
work around it there are also I should
say various types of scientific
literature so the paper that I was just
describing and the paper that we're
going to look at today are both examples
of original research so I mentioned
these present the research you know the
author's hypotheses their methods and
their data but there are also short
reports and letters which kind of tell
shorty research stories review articles
which kind of summarize the salient
findings in a single topic or fields
case studies which you see a lot in
medical journals and those will cover
specific instances of interesting
phenomena like a patient who has unusual
symptoms for a certain disease and there
are also methods papers where authors
can showcase a new method or technique
that they've developed alright so moving
it to the paper that we are going to be
talking about today
um this paper is called Osiris Co v2
protein interaction map reveals targets
for drug repurposing which is a lot of
words to break it down a little bit in
this paper they're going to start by
looking for protein interactions for the
virus Tsarskoe v2 which we all know is
the novel coronavirus which causes kovat
19:00 disease and and we'll talk more
about what protein interaction means
exactly
and then after that they're going to
look for drugs that might be able to be
repurposed or used in a different way to
treat SARS Cody - um and we'll talk a
lot more about this and this is a super
super exciting paper but it's also still
very much the only beginning of research
and there's a ways to go before drugs
like this or drugs from this paper could
be used to treat patients um another
cool thing and one of the reasons I
wanted to talk about this paper is
because of how fast sorry can you go
back for one second no you're right it's
how fast the research has progressed so
you can see or maybe you can't see but
this is actually this is a peer-reviewed
journal article now um but when we
started talking about making this
presentation like a week and a half ago
it was still a preprint um and one of
the reasons why we think that this is
progressed so quickly is because of how
many authors there are on the paper so
there are you go to X ID please thank
you um there are 25 authors um and they
work in over 20 labs across eight
institutions which is a wildly big
collaboration you can see those eight
institutions on the map are the stars
are indicative of them um and you can
see they're mostly located in the US but
there are also some European labs and I
think it's just been really cool to see
how the scientific community has really
come together to try to understand
Tsarskoe v2 and how to potentially treat
it also really cool about this paper
it's art even though it's just come out
it's already been highlighted in the
news and so um its findings have been
discussed in the New York Times as well
as in the conversation so now we're
gonna turn things over and start talking
about the body of the paper great so
Before we jump in we'd actually like to
take a little bit of time to sort of
explore some key terms that have
important roles in the paper but that
you might be unfamiliar with so those
terms are protein protein interactions
bio tropism phases of drug development
sort of
subtly and mass spectrometry so
protein-protein interactions so if you
think of ourselves as factories the
proteins are the workers they're the
ones carrying out all the various
functions that ourselves do to basically
keep our bodies working and healthy and
doing what they need to do and a big
part of how proteins do their particular
jobs is by physically interacting with
each other so this works at sort of like
3d surfaces and proteins that are
complementary so if you imagine puzzle
pieces sticking together that's exactly
how this works and basically once these
complementary services find each other
they then get held together by chemical
bonds that form in between them so in
ourselves proteins physically interact
to enable certain kinds of jobs for
example some jobs can only take place if
the proteins are together in the complex
that are enabled by these interactions
sometimes these interactions can allow
one protein to make a chemical change to
another one that then affects the
activity about other protein
interactions can also allow proteins to
move around the cell to different places
to do specialized jobs in those places
and where to go and protein interactions
can assist or prevent other protein
interactions that might otherwise be
possible so a very important thing to
know too is that lots of drugs work by
blocking disease related protein protein
interactions and in our paper the
authors are not only looking for protein
protein interactions that also drugs
that can disrupt them so another term
that we wanted to take a look at was
viral tropism so bio tropism is the
ability of a virus to infect a specific
host and this can happen at various
levels of biology for example at the
cellular level we know that HIV can
infect macrophages which is a kind of
immune cell but it doesn't infect
neurons which are cells in their brains
the flu virus infects our lung tissue
but not our brain tissue and even if the
whole organism level myxoma is an
example of a virus that
rabbits but doesn't infect us humans and
basically what determines whether a
virus can infect a specific host is the
presence of certain things called host
factors so these are cellular resources
that a virus hijacks in order to infect
and replicate within its host
so for SARS Coby - which we know can
infect bats monkeys humans and maybe
some house pets we know that a host
factor that it relies upon is the ACE -
receptor which is a protein that is
expressed in our cells that SARS Kobe -
actually uses to enter ourselves during
infection so the office of our paper are
looking for more host factors
essentially like a stew that SARS copy -
viruses need by looking for viral human
protein interactions all right so the
authors of our paper report that they
find drugs that come from preclinical
studies clinical trials and our fda
approved so you wanted to take a beat
and kind of break down what each of
these sort of phases of drug development
actually means
so whenever our lab say at a drug pharma
company finds a drug that they think
could be effective in treating some
disease the first step for that drug is
to go into preclinical studies so at
this step the drugs assess for safety
and animals oftentimes mice and
basically during these studies
scientists will take measurements like
where the drug goes in the body sort of
what organs it hangs out in how long it
stays there whether the drug gets broken
down into smaller molecules that might
have different effects and once all this
data is collected the FDA then reviews
it and decides whether the drug can go
into clinical trials so clinical trials
are what you hear about in the news that
are like phase 1 2 & 3 all that applies
to this step in the process and these
trials take place in patients and
healthy volunteers who receive either
either the drug or a placebo and their
purpose is to make sure that the drug is
effective is safe and then once the FDA
reviews a whole other bunch of data from
the clinical trials they decide whether
to approve or reject the drug and if
it's approved then you can buy it it
goes in the market and it could be
prescribed
patience so we have a little poll for
you guys um on average how long do you
think it takes for a drug to progress
from preclinical studies to FDA approval
so one end of that flowchart all the way
to the other all right I think we're
starting to level out I'm going to close
the poll and like maybe 10 seconds or so
[Music]
5 4 3 2 1 all right so actually ooh this
is interesting okay so three to five
years
I like the optimism it's actually 10 to
12 years so this actually kind of makes
our point pretty well and that that's
not you know an insignificant amount of
time um but that's also why this this
idea of repurposing drugs
oh sorry okay maybe now you can see it
hold on okay I guess we got it okay but
that's why the idea of repurposing drugs
is so appealing because if you know if
you have like a brand new drug that
still to undergo preclinical studies all
the clinical trials and everything that
can take 10 to 12 years but if say if
you have a drug that's already FDA
approved even though it would have to be
reproved to be used in a different
disease and the one that it was
originally approved for because we
already have some data from preclinical
studies we have an idea of how safe it
isn't people and what doses are
appropriate that process from like
starting to getting improved is a lot
faster than it would be if the drug was
brand new so that's why we're trying to
look for drugs that we can be purposed
for Co good so we can get them into the
clinic and to our patients more quickly
all right so this last vocab word that
we're going to go over or vocab concept
is
method that the author's use so in this
paper the author's are trying to
identify the human proteins that
interact with viral proteins as we've
mentioned before um but the scientists
have to figure out how do they go from
having this unknown prototype protein
how do they identify it um and so the
tool that they use to identify it click
please is a tool known as mass
spectrometry or a mass spec for short
because spectrometry is like kind of a
mouthful to say um and mass spec is a
tool that scientists can use to identify
proteins as well as on other molecules
and in this paper it is used for the
authors to be able to figure out what
human proteins interact with viral
proteins next slide so going into a
little bit more about what how mass
spectrometry works spectrometry is a big
word as I mentioned hard to say but it
really describes a method of studying a
spectrum like in this case mass other
types of spectrometry can look at things
like color or fluorescence and a mass
spectrometer works by measuring how much
mass there isn't an object depending on
its charge so it can basically is used
to calculate the mass to charge ratio
for each molecule so for sorry so we
have some videos kind of to illustrate
this I know I'm not gonna like act it
out that would be weird so to the first
video is to show the first step of mass
spec which is ionization so as you can
see here a mass spectrometer starts by
breaking up a molecule in this case of
protein into smaller bits called ions
and so now all of these smaller circles
or spheres have broken up they have to
be sorted and so these ions or in the
video little circles are go through an
electromagnet which separates them on
the basis of their mass in charge so you
can see that the in this video the
little blue balls are traveling faster
and the red ones are traveling slower
because they're bigger and then finally
um
all of these sorted ions need to be
detected and so in this step the
mass-to-charge ratio for each ion is
graphed so that we can see how many ions
of each mass-to-charge ratio there are
in the sample and so the results from a
mass spectrometer kind of look like this
piecemeal graph where you see how big
each individual ion is and then you can
put that information together together
sort of like a puzzle to identify the
protein you put in at the beginning and
so now that we kind of have a basis of
the concepts in this paper the two
questions that the authors are trying to
ask are first what human proteins
interact with the SARS Coby to viral
proteins and second are there drugs
against these human proteins that can be
repurposed to treat Koba 19 and how are
they going to do this they use a type of
scientific reasoning that is known as
experimental evaluation there's lots of
different ways that scientific knowledge
can be created lots of different
approaches for that these these authors
use a series of controlled experiments
to understand what viral and human
proteins interact and what drugs might
be potentially helpful in disrupting
those interactions and so to actually
perform these experiments the authors
began sorry next slide thank you to
perform these experiments the authors
began by identifying human proteins that
interact with viral proteins so they
looked into the virus's genome or
genetic material and some of these viral
proteins are already known and then the
others were predicted based off of what
we know about coronaviruses and DNA
translation in general and so okay and
so obviously no one really wants to get
those virus proteins put into their
bodies to see what proteins the virus
interacts with in humans and so a way
that scientists can still study human
cell is to use something called a cell
line and so cell lines are cells that
are originally taken from an organ
some in this case humans that are
treated with a bunch of different things
so that they can grow indefinitely in
the lab generally and some kind of
plastic plate very something and so most
cell lines have been kept in labs for a
really long time so there are some
caveats because the cells aren't exactly
they don't have all the same properties
as a cell in your body would have but
they are kind of the best we have
because we're not going to go around
putting viral proteins into people um
and so in this piece the authors chose
to use a human kidney cell line and they
expressed a single viral protein at a
time and so again this isn't exactly
like what would happen during a viral
infection normally viruses don't only
infect your cells with one protein at a
time but this helps the authors to
identify the specific interactions
between a single viral protein and the
human proteins and so once all these
human cells were expressing or they made
the viral protein they first opened the
human cells and they took out all of the
proteins and they did this in a way so
that all of the proteins could still be
interacting with each other so they
maintained all those human protein viral
protein interactions and then from this
protein soup that they made they pulled
out the viral proteins and everything
that was attached to them and so from
there they have the viral protein
connected with the human protein and
they can use mass spectrometry which I
talked about earlier to identify the
human proteins and finally they put all
of this data together into these really
pretty graphs that M is going to talk
about in much more detail but these maps
show the protein protein interactions
alright so in total of the 26 Tsarskoe
b2 proteins the authors express in these
human cells they find 332 human proteins
that interact with them and then of
those 332 human proteins 66 were
druggable which means that we have we
know of drugs that can bind to them so
then they looked at all those drugs that
emerged and you can see if they come
from those various phases of drug
development that we talked
a little while ago and they picked 47 of
those drugs to move into viral and
activity asses so basically these are
experiments that look at the drugs and
see if they can if they reduce the
ability of stars Kobe to to infect cells
in any way which we want to see them do
if we thought they could be effective in
Kobe 19 patients so to kind of break
down a little bit further what their
data look like so these are two of those
interaction maps that ones you mentioned
as you can see there's a lot of
information here and there are actually
26 of these in the paper
one for each viral protein so overall
this paper generated here these authors
I should say generated a ton of data but
just to kind of break down ref you're
looking at so we chose sort of two viral
proteins or interaction maps as exempt
examples of the data one of the viral
proteins is Wharf 9c which is a protein
the authors predicted to exist based on
looking at the Stars Kobe two genome and
the other one is NSP six which we know
is involved in replicating the stars
Kobe two genome so each of these viral
proteins are here's the red diamonds and
then kind of at the periphery in gray we
can see the human proteins that don't
have known drugs that bind to them at
least yet and in yellow are the proteins
that do have drugs that we know can bind
to them also pretty cool are these
spokes that connect the human proteins
to the viral protein so these based on
their shading and thickness actually
give information about the statistical
confidence that the authors calculated
between each of these interactions so if
you look down here this missed score for
example is a like statistical
calculation between each interaction and
then I think the coolest part of these
at least are these sort of blue clouds
that you see kind of like in these
clusters of different human proteins so
these indicate that the proteins in the
cluster all share the same biological
process and those are written here in
bold so for example these three proteins
that are in this cloud are all involved
in ion transport which is basically just
moving in chemical ions back and forth
between membranes inside of ourselves
and the sort of cool thing about
identifying these shared biological
processes is that they gave us an idea
of not only the proteins that are Scobie
to interacts with but also possibly the
general functions in ourselves that
Tsarskoe be to is hijacking when it's
infecting and replicating ourselves or
in ourselves so here are the same two
interaction maps that we looked at
before only now the druggable proteins
are highlighted and the drugs that match
them are listed in these little text
boxes so you can see if the FDA approved
drugs that some of them might sound a
bit familiar
for example metformin is a drug for type
2 diabetes
haloperidol or Haldol is an
anti-psychotic drug chloroquine and anti
malarial is also in a relative of
hydroxychloroquine that's usually used
to for patients with autoimmune
disorders like lupus or rheumatoid
arthritis and they've also both been in
the news quite a bit over the past few
months for kovat 19 so one cool thing to
know well one thing to note I should say
with these fda-approved drugs is that
that's great
as we heard a little while ago if they
are effective they can be approved for
Koba 19 much faster than a drug that it
was just made brand-new but this also
means or I guess this can also mean that
because these drugs were designed for
different purposes originally and for a
different disease that they could have
effects in our bodies apart from
treating Kovach 19 even if we take them
for Koba 19 but that's the sort of thing
that would be figured out in clinical
trials alright so now that these authors
have found all of these drugs that could
potentially be useful in treating the
virus by disrupting viral protein human
protein interactions they wanted to test
and see if these drugs actually impacted
the ability of the virus to infect cells
again the caveat is cells aren't people
they're not organisms but this is a
common first step that scientists use to
see if it's worth spending the resources
to test these drugs in more preclinical
and clinical applications and so what
they did is
they took cells this time from a monkey
cell line and they began treating them
with the drug of interest and so after
two hours the drugs they wanted to ask
the question if the drug prevents or
decreases the ability of the virus to
infect the cells so after two hours they
infected the drug treated cells and
control cells that don't have drug
treatment with the virus and they kind
of let the virus do its thing for two
days and the ultimate readout was
looking to see if viral infection was
reduced and they did this so the
expectation is if the drug in fact does
prevent viral infection you would see a
reduction of viral infection or maybe
even no viral infection at all whereas
if the drug didn't actually do anything
which is totally possible then viral
infection would still occur normally and
they measured the level of virus by
looking at the viral proteins and the
levels of viral RNA
so the authors took those 69 drugs that
they identified some of them being at
the approved some in clinical trials
some preclinical and they tested on 47
of them in this infectivity assay to see
if the drug prevented or decreased viral
infection and so this is an example of
what one of those assays looks like this
is a drug called PB 28 and just to walk
you through this graph a little I know
there's a lot going on the black line
corresponds with the number of living
cells and this is important because we
don't want the drug to kill the cells we
just want it to prevent viral infection
and the red line is the level of viral
proteins and then on the y-axis we have
percent so the way you would read this
graph is the black line corresponds to
the percentage of cells that are alive
and the red line corresponds with the
percentage of viral proteins in the cell
and then on the x-axis we have the
amount of drug and so this is also
important you might imagine that giving
a lot of drug to the cells might lead to
the virus infecting the cells less but
it also could be more toxic to the cells
and kill be more likely to kill them and
so in this example the PB 28 drug seems
to reduce infectivity which is awesome
you can see that by the decrease in the
red line over the amount of drug and so
but this is just one example not all of
those 47 drugs that they tested did
actually reduce infectivity um and what
it would look like if the drug didn't
reduce infectivity is you would have
like a flat red line just to show that
there is no effect and so of the drugs
that did seem to reduce infectivity
there were two major classes there -
like groups um the first being drugs
that bind the Sigma 1 Sigma 2 receptor
and the second being drugs that prevent
making a new protein so PB 28 is
actually an example of that first class
of drugs that find - the Sigma 1 Sigma 2
receptor and then you would imagine it
kind of like I don't know hand wavy kind
of makes sense that drugs that prevent
making new proteins might
also prevent viral infection all right
so now that we've looked at at least
some representative data from the paper
let's revisit those questions that we
mentioned the beginning so question 1
with the authors set out to ask in their
study is what human proteins interact
with SARS Kobe - viral proteins and then
question 2 are there drugs against these
human proteins that could be repurposed
for covin 19 so one thing that I think
is generally kind of a good practice to
take whenever you're looking at a study
it's not only see what the authors found
out but also what they didn't find out
you know every paper that's out there
will present a lot of data but also
leave some questions unanswered and by
kind of consciously being aware of those
you can not only see exactly how far a
study pushed our knowledge forward but
also keep an eye out for the things that
it didn't answer and then for the
research that's working to answer it and
follow-up so for question one we can say
the authors did identify human proteins
332 of them that sorta Scobie two
proteins enter a quiz and they also
showed evidence that some of these
interactions are important to Tsarskoe
b2 viral infect infectivity and actually
the authors work in identifying these
human proteins or SARS kovita tube coat
or host factors actually well not only
points us towards drugs that might be
useful in treating code 19 because they
bind the human proteins but they also
advance our understanding about the
kinds of cell functions that Tsarskoe be
to hijacks when it's in our cells and
this understanding could also help us
progress towards therapy itself because
although we know that well we have
reason to think that drugs that bind
these specific proteins they found it
might be disruptive we can also look for
drugs that disrupt these general
functions that might have not been
captured in this paper and we can also
test those and see if there's
therapeutically viable as well so for
question two the authors also identified
drugs that might be able to disrupt the
human viral protein interactions and
at least in their asses that Lindsay
just showed us some of these drugs
showed antiviral activity but very
importantly the authors did not find a
treatment that we can start giving to
cope in 19 patients right away and
that's because the conditions and their
experiments compared to the conditions
in our human bodies are so different
that we can't possibly effect we can't
possibly predict rather all of the
effects that these drugs would have in a
coded nineteen patient so as Lindsay
mentioned one way in which this is the
case is that all these experiments
happened in cell lines and some lines
are immortalized as we call it which
means they can grow in a lab in some
plastic in a solution with like sugar
and just do that indefinitely and be
really happy and as you can imagine for
cells to be able to do that they have to
take on a certain like some certain
behaviors that are much different than
the cells in their bodies actually do so
that already makes this system quite a
bit different in terms the experimental
system from what the human body would be
like another caveat is that these cells
also don't account for certain variables
that would be very important to how
patients respond to this therapy so when
you think about it like patients can
have all sorts of different genetic
differences between them just from one
person to another they can have other
medical conditions they can even be on
other drugs to treat those medical
conditions and all of those would not be
sort of factored in to the experiments
that are done in these cell lines and
would also have an effect on how these
patients respond to cope in nineteenth
era peas now this isn't to say that like
you know the results in this study are
not useful or they're unreliable to the
contrary I mean just based those two
interact ohms as I said there were 26 of
those so there's a lot of data in this
paper it came out superfast is like a
testament to this power of this
collaboration and there's a lot here
that'll be very useful to other
researchers in the field moving forward
and this is also not to say - if the
drugs they found won't necessarily be
useful to treat co19
it's just that we can't say that yet
without actually testing them clinical
trials so on that note let's take a look
sort of hypothetically at one of the
drugs that came from this paper to see
what its path might look like through
the clinical trial process so there's a
lot going on here but we'll break it
down and work through it so as I
mentioned at the top of the webinar when
I drug kind of like after it's developed
in lab and is right ready to go into
clinical trials or at least hopefully it
undergoes as preclinical testing and
animals and then once the company runs
these preclinical tests they gather all
that data and submit it to the FDA in
what's called an investigational new
drug application so this application has
all that data and it also has a
description of the company's plans for
actually running those clinical trials
so if the FDA approves this application
then the drug gains investigational new
drug status which basically just means
that it can be shipped across state
lines to be used in clinical trials so
then the drug goes into these phase 1 2
& 3 at a minimum clinical trials and as
I mentioned before clinical trials take
place and healthy volunteers and in
patients with the disease depending upon
the phase they'll be treated with a drug
or a placebo and then their responses we
monitored over a set period of time
so clinical trials are designed to do to
figure out two very specific things
about a drug firstly its efficacy which
is basically how good the drug is at
heal at treating the disease that's
supposed to treat in terms of leave
eating symptoms or healing the patient
depending on what the drug is for and it
also measures the toxicity of the drug
which means the side-effects the drug
has and how severe those side effects
are so in Phase one clinical trials
which typically lasts about several
months the drug is tested in healthy
volunteers and here they're looking for
they're looking at the safety of the
drug and they're also deciding dosing
ranges that will be appropriate to test
in patients in the next phase so once
the drug passes phase one then it goes
into Phase two and now it's given to
patients with the disease the drug is
actually designed to treat so here we
have quite a few more participating
participants um
and this phase and in the previous one
and it also lasts a bit longer going
from several months like up to a year
and then following Phase two then the
joy moves into phase three clinical
trials which is still in patients that
have the disease that the drug is meant
to treat but now there are way more of
them on the order of hundreds to
thousands and this phase also takes
quite a bit longer usually in the realm
of one to four years so here as in Phase
two they're still looking at the drugs
efficacy its toxicity and kind of
narrowing down doses that would be
appropriate to use in the clinic once
the drug is approved but in Phase three
in particular they're also looking for
rare side effects that you'll be less
likely to find when you're testing the
drug in a fewer people as you are in
Phase two
so when you see drug commercials at the
very end
the narrator kind of like whispers extra
side effects at you like a secret a lot
of those show up in phase three clinical
trials so after all the clinical trial
data is gathered and the trials are done
and the company packages that up into
what's called a new drug application
they're usually at least a hundred
thousand pages long so it's a lot of
data and the FDA reviews that and then
at that point either approves or rejects
the drug at which point it can be
marketed and it can be used to treat
patients so as I mentioned before FDA
approved drugs that are approved for one
disease must be reproved before they can
be used to treat a different disease so
now to look at one of our hypothetical
drugs PB 28 is the one that Lindsay
showed us some ineffective infectivity
data for that looked really good but
because it's not an approved drug it's
actually quite far at the very beginning
of the pipeline it would be entering
here in the preclinical phase and as we
learned at the beginning that means it
could be like 10 to 12 years between
this drug actually entering the pipeline
and coming out at the other end and
being FDA approved if it makes it
through the pipeline at all
by contrast from disappear which is a
drug for koban 19 possible that's being
tested for Coppa 19 that's been in the
news quite a bit lately was developed as
a general antiviral it was actually in
Phase two clinical trials back in 2015
and during the Ebola
break and entered phase three clinical
trials this past February in a trial
that included some covert 19 patients
and it's still in that phase of trials
right now and actually there's kind of a
special sort of caveat with room visibie
so as of last week because of some
preliminary results that suggests that
it might be shortening the duration of
disease in certain patients and the fact
that it's just looking kind of promising
the FDA granted what's called emergency
use authorization
herim disappear which means that even
though it's not FDA approved yet doctors
can prescribe it to patients that have
severe symptoms so as I mentioned like
this rule about approving drugs for a
new disease still holds true but given
the promise of this drug and the special
circumstances that we're in with co19
there are some exceptions that can be
made so that way these drugs that look
promising can get to patients they can
help even sooner all right and one last
thing but I want to share here so
resources that I found are pretty
helpful and kind of just looking into
you know a bunch of koban 19 clinical
trials that are going on and sort of
preparing for this data for the people
presentation I've listed here so stat
news.com has a really nice koban 19
clinical trial tracker it's a very
reader friendly really up to date and
has like nice descriptions of what the
drugs actually do and how they actually
work the FDA of course has great
information about how these Comeau
trials are happening
they also issue frequent press releases
with new findings like that emerges the
use use authorization that I talked
about and lastly if you want to see all
of the kovin 19 show up trials going on
all over the world those are available
at clinical trials.gov and they actually
have them from the w-h-o database that's
the fullest list alright so we just
wanted to end this presentation by
highlighting how this was a totally
massive amount of data and the reason
why that why the authors were able to
generate all this data is because of the
fact that there were 125 authors in over
20 labs and eight institutions and
also just thought that it was super nice
that in addition to the fact that
there's already this massive
collaboration the authors have also done
a really good job of making all parts of
their research as accessible and
transparent as possible including
writing in the paper what their next
step plans are for testing these drugs
and they're also really willing to
distribute materials to other labs so
that other labs can participate and help
testing so we wanted to highlight this
by one of the quotes from the paper that
just like made us all feel a little
happy and kind of optimistic in these
very uncertain times and this quote says
given the urgent and acute global need
for Tsarskoe VT research will make these
resources available to the scientific
community upon completion as we have
done with this study and so we just
thought that was really cool and it's
nice to know that scientists are all
collaborating and working together to
try to figure this out